today we're going to do some live coding
and we're going to do something which
sounds impossible but it's actually
quite natural and practical and that's
programming with infinite data
structures and we're going to be using
house girl for this but it doesn't
matter if you don't know anything about
how scale because I'm going to explain
everything in a simple way as we go
along the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to start up the Haskell
system which we're going to be using
which is called G HCI
and if you'd like to try this stuff out
for yourself this is really available
online just search for the obvious thing
before we start thinking about infinite
data structures we're going to do a
little bit of computation with a simple
finite data structure which is a finite
list so here's a finite list in s cow
it's just a list of numbers between 1
and 20 and it's written 1 or 20 and if
we ask the Haskell system to evaluate
that and we'll just expand it out to
give the numbers between 1 and 20 and
then we can think well what can we
actually do with the finite list so for
example we could sum the list up and we
get the expected answer 210 we could say
well maybe we want to square all the
numbers between 1 and 20 so we can map
the squaring function over the list from
1 to 20 and we get the first 20 squares
what else could we do well maybe we want
to filter out the even numbers from the
list between 1 and 20 and we can do that
we just write filter even from 1 to 20
or if he wants to be a little bit more
fancy we could combine everything we've
done up to this point and we could say
what is the sum of the squares of all
the even numbers between 1 and 20 and
hopefully 15 40 is the correct answer so
here's a little example of a finite list
1 up to 20 and then we've seen for small
examples of simple kinds of computation
which we could do on that finite list
but the video today is about infinite
data structures in particular we're
going to be talking about infinite lists
so how do we do infinite lists in a
language like Haskell well it's very
simple rather than writing something
like 120 we just say 1 dot dot and when
I press return this will be the infinite
list of all the natural numbers
beginning with 1 and this is going to go
on forever but I can interrupt and you
can see we've already got up to
about 196 thousands here okay so it runs
it runs quite quickly so this is an
infinite list so what can we actually do
with an infinite list so let's try some
of the things which we tried before
first of all so maybe we can sum it so
let's try summing the infinite list of
all the numbers beginning with one and I
press that and of course this doesn't
actually work because there's an
infinite number of values in this list
and we try and sum them all it's now
we're going to finish so I need to
interrupt this one here let's try
something else maybe I can try filtering
the even numbers from an infinite list
and hopefully this will work
and yes it does what we get this time is
we get the infinite list of all the even
numbers okay so you can see there's no
odd numbers in the list here what we're
actually doing is we're taking an
infinite data structure as an input
we're taking an infinite list and we're
processing it and we're giving an
infinite data structure as an output
we're taking an infinite list in and
giving an infinite list out which is
quite an interesting idea so let's try
another example let's try filtering all
the numbers less than 100 from the
infinite list beginning with 1 and this
kind of works but not quite there's a
little problem at the end so we get all
the numbers from 1 up to 99 which is
exactly what we expect but now it's just
sitting here and that's because it's
basically trying to find another number
which is less than 100 and it will never
succeed with that but it doesn't know
it's not going to find one so it will go
on forever ok so I have to break out of
this one and this again illustrates the
idea that when you're programming with
infinite data structures you need to be
careful we try to summon infinite data
structure and it didn't work
it just went immediately into an
infinite loop we're trying to filter
here from an infinite data structure and
it gave us the expected results but in
the end it just hung so you need to be
careful with this kind of thing let's
try one more example let's try taking 20
elements from the infinite list
beginning with 1 and this of course
works we just get exactly what we expect
we get the numbers between 1 and 20
we're taking an infinite data structure
as an input we're taking the infinite
list of all the values from 1 onwards
and we're getting a finite data
structure as the output we're getting a
finite list of all the numbers between 1
and 20 how do
this kind of behavior actually work and
it's to do with the evaluation order
which you have in your programming
language most languages are what's
called strict or eager and that means
when you have a parameter like this
infinite list
you completely evaluate that parameter
before you try and do anything with it
so if you're in an eager or strict
language and you try and run take 20 of
an infinite list it's never going to get
anywhere because it will just attempt to
evaluate the infinite list and then will
never stop you'll never actually get any
result but languages like Haskell are
lazy when you have a parameter in
Haskell you only evaluate it on demand
so the demand here is that we want to
take 20 elements from the infinite list
so the two parts here take 20 and the
infinite list they kind of collaborate
together and say well we only actually
need to generate 20 elements to proceed
so we don't actually generate the entire
infinite list so in Haskell when we
write one up to infinity it's not really
an infinite list it's a potentially
infinite list which gets evaluated as
much as required by the context in which
we use it there are some small little
examples let's maybe trying something a
bit more interesting now let's try and
write a program which generates all the
prime numbers the infinite list of all
prime numbers so let's remind yourself
what a prime number is so a number is
prime if it's only factors so that's the
numbers that divide into it exactly are
1 and itself so for example 7 is prime
because it's got two factors 1 and 7 but
15 is not prime because it's got four
factors so let's write a program to do
this so first of all we're going to
write a small function called factors
which is going to return all the numbers
which divide exactly into a number so if
I give it a number like n I'm going to
return all the values X such the X comes
from the list 1 up to n and if I take
the remainder when I divide n by X and
that had better be 0 so this is just
running over all the numbers between 1
and the given number and it could be
clever here and write square root of n
but let's just keep it simple you run
over all the numbers between 1 and the
given number and you just check is the
remainder when I divide one by the other
so for example if I say what's the
factors of seven I just get two factors
one and seven so that's a prime number
and if I say what's the factors of 15 I
get four factors one three five and
fifteen so that's not a prime number and
this tells us basically how we can
define a very simple program to check if
a number is prime I can say a number n
is prime if and only if if I look at its
factors if I get back exactly the list 1
and n so that's my definition of what it
means to be a prime number now I can
check that this actually works I can say
is 7 a prime number and it says true
because it is exactly two factors and I
can say is 15 a prime number and I get
false because it's got more than two
factors now we've got all we need to
actually generate the infinite list of
all prime numbers and we can use you can
do this simply using the filter function
if we just no filter all the prime
numbers from the infinite list beginning
with one then as soon as I hit return
this thing will start generating the
infinite list of all prime numbers ok
and you can see here it's already gone
quite far we've got up to about 16,000
and you can check that all of these
numbers are actually prime but actually
this is quite a modern laptop we'd
expect this program to run much faster
than this so what we'd like to do now is
see how we can take this simple means of
producing the infinite list of all the
prime numbers and actually make it go a
lot faster by using a two
thousand-year-old algorithm did they
have all the rhythms 2000 years ago
yesterday the ancient Greeks discovered
many things including many interesting
algorithms so here is a here is a 2000
year old algorithm which is called the
sieve of Eratosthenes after a Greek
mathematician and this is a very very
simple algorithm for generating the
infinite list of all the prime numbers
so let's see how it actually works the
first step is we write down the infinite
list 2 3 4 all the way up to infinity
the second step is we mark the first
value P so that's going to be 2 as being
a prime number the third step is to
remove all the multiples of P so
initially that will be 2 from the list
and the fourth step is that we go back
to the second step so it's a very simple
four step process for generating all the
prime numbers and an interesting
observation here
the infinity occurs all over the place
in this algorithm we're writing down an
infinite list at the beginning we're
removing an infinite number of elements
from an infinite list in step 3 and then
we're having an infinite loop in step 4
because we're looping around here
forever so let's see how this 2,000 year
old algorithm actually works in practice
with a little example so the first step
in the algorithm was we write down all
the numbers from 2 up to infinity so
let's stop at 12 but of course in
principle we go on forever here then the
next step is we mark the first value in
the list as being a prime number so
we'll say 2 is our first prime number
then we need to remove all the multiples
of 2 from the list and let's do this by
putting a small barrier under all the
multiples of 2 so that's the even
numbers oops forgot 11 and we'll think
of these barriers as kind of stopping
these numbers falling down the page so
we imagine the numbers trying to fall
down the page now so the 3 you'll fall
down the 5 or fall down and in general
all the odd numbers are fall down
because the even numbers are stopped by
a little barrier and you can think of
this as being a sieve this is why it's
called the sieve of eratosthenes because
you're blocking some numbers from coming
down the page and then we go back to the
start again so 3 is a prime number and
then we put a small barrier under all
the multiples of 3 so 6 is already gone
9 and 12 and then the numbers that are
not stopped by the barrier or sipped out
they come down the page so 5 comes down
7 comes down 11 comes down we continue 5
is a prime number we remove all the
multiples of 5 the numbers come down the
page and so on so you can see the basic
idea here we're generating in a very
simple way all the prime numbers we're
getting 2 3 5 7 and eventually 11 and so
on so that's the algorithm what we're
going to do now is think how can we
actually implement this in our a
programming language and we'll see that
it we actually only need a two-line
program to implement this it's a very
direct translation of the
two-thousand-year-old algorithm into an
actual working program so let me start
up an editor and we're gonna write a
program now so we're going to generate
the infinite list of all the prime
numbers and I'm going to define that by
sibling
the infinite list starting from two so
the first step of the algorithm was we
write down old numbers from 2 onwards so
that's what we've got here and then
we're going to pass it into a function
called sieve which we haven't written
yet which is going to do all the other
steps for us so what is sieve do well
sieve is going to take the list apart so
P will be the first thing in the list so
that's initially going to be 2 and peas
will be everything else so that's 3 4 5
etc all the way up to infinity and then
what we're going to do on the right hand
side is we'll keep the first value so
that's like marking the first number as
being prime and then we're going to
recursively sieve something so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna save out
all the numbers which are not multiples
of P what this part in the brackets here
does is it takes the infinite list of
all the remaining numbers so 3 all the
way up to infinity and it's going to
remove all the multiples of 2 so it's
just running over the list and it's
removing all the numbers which are
multiples of 2 so this will remove the
four of the six of the eight and the so
on and then we just call ourselves
recursively again and this is the entire
program so actually the program is
shorter than the English description we
had of the algorithm it's useful to
actually think how does each step
actually get represented here well the
first step was we write down the numbers
from 2 up to infinity which is here the
second step is we mark the first value
as being prime so that's the value P
here the third step is we remove all the
multiples of P so all the multiples of
two initially from the list and that's
the part here and then the final step is
we run the algorithm again from step 2
and that's calling the sieve function so
we've got our program here so let's see
it actually working so let me start up
the Haskell system again good we've got
no errors which is good so let's run the
prime number program and here we get all
the prime numbers again so it gives
exactly the same results as the simpler
algorithm which we wrote before but it
does so a lot more quickly and if you do
some simple experiments for a numbers up
to this color size it runs about 10
times faster than the simple algorithm
which we had previously so what could we
do with this well we could do a whole
bunch of things so for example if I want
to
a hundred prime numbers I don't know
need to write a program which generates
100 prime numbers I just take the
infinite list of all the prime numbers
and I take a hundred so I've kind of
separated my control part which is
taking a hundred numbers from my data
part which is having an infinite list of
primes and this idea of separating
control and data using infinite data
structures is a very powerful way of
thinking about programming and I can do
other things as well
so for example if I wanted to say give
me all the prime numbers less than 100 I
don't need to write a separate program
for that now I just take my infinite
list of all the prime numbers and I say
take while less than 100 and I get that
and in many languages if you wanted to
write these two separate programs you'd
need to write some separate programs
basically but if you can manipulate
infinite data structures you just have
your infinite list of primes and then
you can do whatever you want with them
afterwards you can select what parts you
like just to conclude let me do one
final little example to do with what's
called twin primes so twin primes are
Prime's
which differ by 2 so 3 & 5 are twins
because they're different by 2 5 & 7 are
twins because they differ by 2 7 and 11
are not twins because they differ by 4
so how do we write a program using what
we've already done that generates all
the twin primes so first of all let me
say what it means to be a twin so say a
pair XY is a twin if Y is x plus 2 so
for example if I say is 3 & 5 or twin it
will say true and if I say is 7 and 11
or twin then I get no so how do I use
this to write a program that generates
all the twin primes well what I'm going
to do is I'm going to generate the
infinite list of all the twins and I'm
going to simply filter twin from zip of
primes and kill primes so there's a
couple of bits we haven't seen before
here what is tail do so tail takes a
list which could be infinite and removes
the first thing so if we write tail of
primes what we're going to do is take
the infinite list of all prime numbers
and throw the two away so we'll get 3 5
7 11 etc what zip does is it takes two
lists and they can be finite or infinite
so suppose I've got two less than five
numbers what zip does is it pairs up the
corresponding elements and the two lists
so here
the first thing the second third fourth
and fifth so what is going to do here
with the infinite lists is we're going
to zip the infinite list of all the
prime numbers with the infinite list of
all the prime numbers apart from the
first one so what we're going to get
coming out of this zip is an infinite
list of pairs of each prime number and
the next prime number so we'll get 2 & 3
3 & 5 and so on and so on
and then all we're going to do is take
that infinite list of all of those Paes
and filter the twins out of it and this
is enough to generate all the twin
primes so I can test this out here's all
the infinite list of twin primes and
this is a one-line program to do this
based on a two line program which we had
to generate the infinite list of all the
prime numbers going back to where I
started programming with infinite data
structures sounds impossible but as
we've seen today and I hope to have
convinced you it's actually quite simple
and natural and practical that's all
because Haskell is lazy
yeah it's because of laziness so you can
do this in other programming languages
but essentially you need to fake lazy
evaluation in some way and languages are
providing a bit more support these days
for doing that and there's there's